so the best way to experience the video
API is through a live demo and let's
start by taking this video of a
Superbowl commercial for Google home and
I'm going to play the first few seconds
we can see that it starts as a mountain
landscape and we see a house a city
street then it goes to a dog and a
garage so lots of scene changes
happening in this video and if we were
to manually categorize what was
happening throughout it we need to watch
the entire thing and write down what was
happening in every scene
luckily the video API takes care this
forest which is the single rest API
request so it tells us two things one at
a high level it tells us what is this
video about and then it also tells us
and more granular level what labels it
finds in the video in each scene so if
we scroll down here we can see it
identifies a dog and it can tell us
exactly where in the video that dog
appears it also identifies at the end of
the video there's a birthday cake and if
we scroll down a bit more we can see
that not only does it know it's a dog it
knows what type of dog it is but it's a
dashing and if we scroll down through
the rest of the labels we can see that
it also successfully identifies that
mountain path scenes in the beginning so
this is what the API can do with one
video but you likely have more than one
video that you want to analyze so let's
take a look at how a company might use
the video intelligence API a media
publisher could have hundreds of
petabytes of video data sitting in
storage buckets and one common thing
they might want to do is create a
highlight reel focus on a specific type
of content or search their large library
for a specific entity so let's see how
we would use the video intelligence API
to search a large library of videos
given all this metadata that we get back
from it we've got a lot of videos here
and let's say this media publisher has
hours of sports video but they only want
to find the content relevant to baseball
so let's go ahead and search our library
here for baseball videos and we can see
that not only does it show us which
videos have baseball it tells us exactly
when in those videos baseball appears my
favorite example is this one we have
this video which only has a tiny bit
about baseball but it's able to identify
that clip for us whereas if we were to
manually do this we'd have to watch the
whole video looking for that specific
scene so if we click on this scene we
can see that this is from last year's
your
search video when the Cubs won the World
Series so let's do one more search I
live on the East Coast where it's pretty
cold right now I've heard there's been a
ton of rain in SF this past year I think
we can all agree it'd be pretty nice to
be on a beach right now
and while machine-learning can't take us
there it can do the next best thing and
find all the beach clips in our video
library for us so let's search for our
beach videos and then we can click to
all of our Beach clips in the videos
below so as you saw through this demo
the video intelligence API makes it easy
to quickly and easily understand a large
library of video content something that
was almost impossible just a few months
ago taps the tips that used to take
hours now take seconds with the video
intelligence API and I'm excited to make
it available to all of you today
thank you
[Applause]